i know the bar slightly over to his side
yep it's very early days in this game
this uh opening was the italian game and
uh the players after debating maybe a
slightly rare line slightly uh rare move
order at least of the italian game we've
seen it many times at least the opening
on the tour now we've reached this
position and it's level material but the
one reason maybe white has uh to be
happy here is that the black queen is
vulnerable in the middle of the board
the rule is the general rule of thumb
don't bring your queens out too early
because she's the most valuable piece
any time she gets attacked or hit she
has to run away she has to flee and
that's what's happening right now the
backbone of his whole opening repertoire
throughout last season's tour and
clearly at the beginning of this season
as well
and uh yeah in the world championship
match we saw him defend from the black
side he plays it from the white side
he's the world's leading expert so
for hans i'm slightly concerned that
he's gone into it so willingly but uh
okay let's see how the next few moves go
and wow big decision there because
magnus was just hinting at a pawn
sacrifice it was only a short-term thing
but hans now very ambitiously pushing in
the center ivanka maybe white can
actually jump forward with the knight
and attack the queen and this will mean
that the knight on f3 can actually now
jump into the center or at least has the
possibility to uh knight's bishop may be
on the cards white can simply gang up
against this pawn as well he's done this
he has jumped in and uh in the current
position after black blocked with his
bishop so many tempting moves of course
how did i not make the connection kyle
you're on point
and uh okay so magnus developing the
dark square bishop and as mentioned he
did play one of the few tempting moves
we highlighted white star squared bishop
developing itself to a good square and
uh okay hans he's at least trying to
fight back he's counter-attacking he's
now hitting this white bishop
because okay magnus does go for the move
i said was just too complicated to
calculate he did invest a bit of time
doing that and changing things that's
where the top players really thrive and
that's a really good point because uh i
see a lot of people on twitter saying
hey i'm playing the same openings as
magnus
but i'm losing and he's winning and like
you say it's not just the opening it's
uh the middle game and it's those shifts
yeah it's time for magnus to sacrifice
it definitely is imagine material
advantage now he's got to actually give
black the material advantage maybe
better than previous generations and
there we go magnus sacrificing his rook
but yeah against the very top players in
the world who calculate just as well as
them like magnus
these strategic factors actually become
really really important um so okay he
does go for this the most natural move
in the position and for example if black
is too careless just moves the rook for
example then suddenly some real problems
after a trade here white can start
pushing pawns forward white can even
just capture this knight and this pin is
just really scary for black it's not
good i was going to say the reason you
should put your king here as well is
that you don't want to put it in the
corner because then you walk into the
eye line of the other bishop yeah so the
two white bishops there are still some
pieces in the way but they do have great
eyesight and they
really scare this black king troubles
are not over because you just okay we're
gonna see it white has a past pawn now
look how the bishops just protect
everything white's bishop is a beast in
the center of the board and uh
there we go magnus looking for the
forcing moves as we always talk about
checks captures threats he played a
check oh no sorry he played the capture
and then now he's playing a threat
100 percent confirmed
this is a
devastating position for magnus won't
take porn yeah out of desperation hans
gives back his rook for a bishop but now
white is simply one pawn up for free and
it's not just that this is a discovered
check as we call it white's pawn
stepping out of the way of its bishop
the bishop hitting the black king and
when the black king moves white can just
gobble up another pawn white is two
pawns up for free
and white has the strategic advantages
black's attack it's purely imaginative
uh imaginary here uh it's just
non-existent the white queen guards
everything white's king super safe this
looks strong for white but magnus finds
an even stronger one pushing harry the
h1 up the board and uh undermining the
black queen and the reason this is so
strong is because you just destabilize
these two pieces these remember they are
the dream attacking duo attacking
combination but once you destabilize
them they lose their coordination and
now this capture walks into a simple
double attack a simple fork two pieces
under attack and magnus is about to win
the knight jumps forward with the check
the king
of course steps forward out of the check
and now a queen trade but this only
favors white now you can even just take
the queens off the board capture this
pawn and this poor rook is forced on the
defensive against these two pawns it
can't hold them both yeah and they could
have gone either way
and here it just feels like one bad move
rook has to go and start looking at that
b pawn okay he brings back his knight
the knight at least can do some of the
defensive work but unfortunately white's
rook is going to start introducing
itself to the game
and once that white rook joins in i
think the black pieces are overwhelmed
the rook the bishop and the white pawns
together
yeah i mean they're more than a match
for the black rook and knight yeah i was
going to say there was one tiny danger
but there's not even at that i was like
oh you know maybe if the the knight can
combine itself with the rook in the
right formation there might be something
no there isn't these are the things that
are gonna
be just absolutely killing for white
yeah so the black king trying to gallop
over and trying to rush over to the
rescue of its pieces but as you
mentioned you're back at this pawn
stepping forward
it's just too strong and this one white
pawn the e pawn is paralyzing black's
rook right now black's rook is stuck in
front of this pawn and then the b pawn
will simply step forward deflect away
the black rook and white will make a new
queen and hans you can tell on his body
language he's almost ready to throw in
the towel and resign
but just a couple of last moves uh why
not just show the audience show us why
the position is lost uh but no more
tricks unfortunately for him
and uh there we go two pawns they were
on the sixth rank they've moved up
they've graduated to the seventh rank
and now the black knight attacking the
white rook so be careful but you can
flick in a check gain a bit of time and
i think we're about to have it there we
go magnus takes the win about to make a
new queen
and he's ready for the semi-final magnus
carlsen
will play another semi-final match in
the meltdown champions chester